歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是阿倫
台股超級猛
很猛
全世界最強
這樣子開平盤
然後漲八百點
一盤中就是這樣
一路拉一路拉一路拉
因為今天韓股跟日股沒有表現
昨晚美股費半也沒什麼表現
其實對啊
台子一夜盤也沒表現
因为美股还是笼罩在
9月的升息几率
大幅飙升的状况
但我们有不一样的事情
昨天晚上我们就有看到
所谓的
辉达跟联发科的结盟
没错
恭喜我们发科也加入
AI央行的行列
发科加入了辉达央行
因为辉达去买了
发科的可转债
认购35亿美元
九成
好
那加入到底好不好呢
你的感想是什么
好啊
我說你覺得今天台股會長成這樣
你會意外嗎
我覺得蠻意外的
因為我還是會看一下期貨的表現
期貨其實沒什麼表現
也沒有弱
但這樣子開盤就一路拉到收盤
其實我有點嚇到
就怎麼這到底在拉什麼
你知道今天長的就是我內心的澎湃嗎
就是昨天晚上我看到那個新聞的時候
我就覺得
我對台灣半導體的發展
的景仰如滔滔江水
好
對 湮綿不絕
相信國家 對
真的有這樣的感覺很驕傲
怎麼講呢
不是只因为发歌
不是只因为挥达
是因为发歌现在人人抢
谷歌也要 对不对
然后挥达也要
想当初
想当初怎么样
他在那边手机
对
想当初其实是在一个
大家觉得不会成长的市场
是的
可是顺利切进AI
而且有十年的蓝图
把它一起画出来了
没错
这个跟2010年那个时候的
联发科也是一样
是
就山寨机出生
然后突然就耀声起来
是不是
对
然后十几年后过去之后
又下一个阶段
所以他们其实很会把握时机
好 很棒
然后再来的话
我们台积电
在最近有一系列的论坛
还包括半导体站
都有提到矽光子
市占率跟渗透率会大幅飙升
没错
所以其实矽光
还有今天这个IP股
我们其实都还蛮强势的
那当然台积电今天也不错
不过今天引领大盘的
是我们一次所的发哥
等一下会看一下
那我们来看一下
其实我们刚刚讲的很澎湃
台湾股市很强
但其實美國股市是有一個陰霾在的所以我們也要稍微壓抑一下放打出頭鳥沒错我们来看一下华许在上礼拜五的这个Jackson Hall讲出来的话
就还是如预期的偏阴派一点点
因为他认为通膨就很明确
我的目标就是2%
但现在就是3%多
所以他还是想要偏阴一点的讲法
那目前来说讲完之后
整个9月原本是三成左右的几率
升息直接拉到了66%
真的很高
而且剩没几天
剩两周
9月16
对啊
所以剩两周的时间
会不会就真的给你
迅雷不禁耳的伸出来
其实这两周
还有一些转环的余地
像是要公布的非农
下个礼拜的CPI
只要数字好看一点点
这个机率还是有机会降下来的
对 所以我觉得
我目前还是比较站在
它不太可能升息的角度
因为美赛值率
不管是10年期还是30年期
就已经都涨翻天了
对 那你这个钱都是谁要去出
因为美国政府要出
跟美國財政赤字
因為利息要付很多
所以現在華許其實有點尷尬
因為通膨壓不下來
但如果我繼續升級的話
那美國赤字只會更嚴重
所以它是左右為難 左右夾擊
好 現在就是為難的
川普也很為難
怎麼有派任的人都沒在聽我的
真的 但是他感覺
好像川普比較不罵他
對不對 上一個罵滿兇的
好 再來另外一個就是
今天早上又傳出來
美一又開戰了
然後剛剛我們錄影的
稍早大概一兩個小時前
其實這個油船
有兩顆飛彈射過去
對 所以台子夜盤才又突然
跌下來了 對
那這件事情可能在近期內
還是會持續影響股市
大家還是要注意一下
不管是原油的價格
還是因為原油推升的
美債值率的價格
美債值率的趴數
大家要稍微注意一下
可能在美國股市上
這些都會是短線的陰霾
大家稍微注意一下
好 那我們來繼續看下來
就是這個發哥的部分
回答呢 投資
35億美金
那原本是預計發行
39億的ECB
結果回答呢
就直接就九成去了
包走了
為我而發這種感覺
沒錯沒錯
35億OK買買買
類似這種感覺
那當然也非常好
帶動了今天
聯發科直接一自鎖
就在這裡一根
所以就看一看就覺得
結束了
看期貨8點45分
而且就跟它的可轉載的
轉換價差不多了
是的
所以目前來說發哥
形態上我覺得還沒有
還沒有打出恩自行但當然今天一致說還是沒什麼已經沒什麼好挑剔的然後也帶動一些IP股今天表現不錯創意是自己原本就很強了可能有一些
漲多的一個回落
創高壓回
是的
那其實還有一檔
聯發科有相關的
那就是雍智科
雍智科技探偵系列
對 就是幫聯發科做的
那今天也是一字所
所以後面如果要看一下
有沒有動能延續性
大家再自己斟酌一下
這個是發科的部分
非常不錯
那今天發科全職也在很重
所以漲停之後
其实开盘就不太弱了
那我觉得是好事
因为我们台湾股市指数如果好
那大家的信心就会比较足够一点
再来另外一个就是
整个矽光指在
从8月以来的延续性都还不错
那持续进入9月了
我觉得应该还有一些表现的机会
对 那这个半导体展呢
台积电有来做加持
相关的呢
会说是今年还会在年增50%
是
然后明年会再继续的
向上去做推升
所以目前看起来都还
是一个偏乐观的状态
我们台湾矽光子一直很幸福的
就是台积电其实蛮加持这个族群的
对的
因为它可能做COOP也是
很需要做这种东西
好那有一些相关的
AI半导体的先进封抓
然后跟矽光子的CPU高速传输
还有量子技术
晶圆制造
还有化合物半导体
跟实体AI的中端应用
基本上还是围绕在整个AI发展
从能源到实体应用的状态
去做商机的一些部分
现在反而什么事情都是
规模越来越大
没错
晶圆制造
他们现在谐音梗用得很凶
科技业也沦落了
也喜欢谐音梗
好
那细光子有相关
随着铜线传输进入物理极限
所以细光子是必须要发展的技术
那再来台积电
预约光还有流明光学
都有登台大秀相关的技术
另外CPU技术下半年会正式量产
2027年会渗透率超过了五成
所以目前看起来应该都是一个
火热發展的狀態
雖然我們還在定義
叫做滲透率突破五成
是什麼意思
但是總之台積電這樣講了嘛
所以已經有很多
在創新高的路上了
沒有錯
那我們等一下下半場
要不要跟大家講一下
哪一些是看低做高
看高做低啦 說錯了
看低做高也沒錯
也是動能派的
OK OK OK
好 我們來看一下大盤
大盤呢
我們在前陣子跟大家說
這邊這一根紅K
突破了一個小箱形
那接下來要挑戰的呢
就是這個高點
那這個高點呢在今天是明確的去站上了其實昨天台湾股市就很強昨天我們是反映了週五的滑雪利空所以其實跌了七八百點不過我們在昨天拉了一個
七百點的下影線
然後還沒有跌破任何的均線
五日均跟十日均碰到
再收盤價都有站上
所以就非常的強勢的意思
然後在今天總算做了一個突破
這個突破我覺得就是一個
N字型的確立
這個新高高前高有沒有
這裡新低高前低
所以目前來說我覺得即便出現回落
即便出現漲多震盪
在現在的形態來講的話
我個人認為都是回落要記得上車
對對要上車
那昨天的量比較大
因為昨天MSEI季度調整
所以今天就直接做突破
那我覺得應該就是更好的意思
好那另外給大家幾個關鍵均線
第一個就是月線
你看這邊碰月線拉新高
對
所以這一大段呢
觀察的重點可以拉在月線的部分
好 就是要守在月线上
没错 那再来这一小段呢
目前看起来还没走完
那有回落的时候
给大家一个比较更具体的位置
就是时日均线
时日均线呢
就会代表这一段的行情的关键均线
那这一大段的呢
是月线
所以一个是小的格局
一个是大一点的格局
对 那只要这两个状态都还在
基本上这个行情啊
有回落都不要太怕
相对的如果有回落跌破
那就记得可能涨多
要进入一个高涨争利了
那目前没有
所以目前还是偏向乐观去看待
再来贵买
贵买呢finally
我们这边是七月中跌破
睽違了一个半月
我们终于站回季线了
对 因为贵买长得就显然
没有加全那么健康样
对 但是这两天
或者说这一段时间的走势
其实贵买没有输
因为CPU或者是说一些探针系列的
群职都蛮重的
贵买部分
那今天环球晶也总算有点回神
对啊 因为环球晶占贵买很大群重
是的 所以今天的这个贵买
表现其实是不错的
有涨到2.26%
然后也是有一个季线的突破了
可是高点差一点点
盘中最高点有突破
但它还没有形成一个N字形
这比较可惜一点
但至少占回季线
所以我觉得贵买指数
目前的表现
也值得后面的行情的期待
我觉得大中小股
应该大家都可以好好关注一下
而且成交量我们都陆续回稳
这一段时间成交量都回来了
回到兆了
没错
所以我觉得量能出来了
然後形態也出來了
那我覺得就是好好去關注
有沒有機會有一些動能的股票了
好 那我們接下來看一下新興
因為星星不管
大家會從各個方面來講
不過我覺得單純從形態來看
是不是已經只跌了
我覺得今天這一根超級爆大量
確實在短線上是值得去做一個
短線超底的動作
因為你停順點很好抓
很好抓 我們說高檔爆量的時候
要記得跑嘛 對不對
那低檔爆量的時候呢
可以接看看
為什麼 因為今天最低點911
可是我好怕它無量跌停的那種感覺
我覺得這樣比較難
難喔
對 這樣很難在底部無量跌停了
因為已經一堆人衝進去
跟你洗來洗去 低點911
對啊 沒錯 我有記的
收盤價971嘛
所以你今天如果尾盤做進場
提損點就是今天低點跌破
那表示什麼 換手失敗
這個這麼大的量一定大幅度換手
換手失敗今天好可怕
9萬多耶
可是你的停損就60塊
但是如果你換回來 漲回去
那你至少這邊跌停
這一根是會賺回來的
對 那你要不要看
要不要用只可能5-6%的空间
去换个10%以上的涨幅
其实我觉得单就强短
这个角度来讲
我觉得今天是值得试试看的
但是以他们目前产业的角度来讲
其实我觉得可能要再停看
停一下
对因为他们这次
其实大家应该都知道
我们就不赘述了
他就是讲的是
他ABF是最占钱的
但是被减掉的是PCB的部分
那PCB的部分占整个新兴的营收
其实不到三成
而且毛利率最好的ABF
其实是完全不受影响的
对那以战略这个角度来讲
这种事件其实
照常来讲
长线应该合理回去
股价是要回去的
但重点是这个检掉
才刚开始两三天
那又还没有整个检掉完毕
所以后面会不会有
更重要的状态
这个我们也不知道
那如果有
这个可能就要继续走回落
那相对的如果结束了
那我觉得行情就结束
那时候再来买
其实也不会太迟
所以我觉得
以站在事件性的角度来讲
我会等事件确立的
再来看要不要进场
好 而且也不要
昨天就怕自己卖不掉
今天觉得千万不要卖
好像很厉害了
就是一天不同的情绪
情绪都不太一样
而不是有任何的纪律
可能也是要避免的
是的 所以星星
大家如果跟短线
跟产业角度来讲
想法是完全不一样
大家来自己参考了
好 既然你有注意到
关键数字
你知道八月份
涨了几点吗
是一个关键数字
八月份你说大盘吗
对啊
大盘涨几点
大盘涨了3008
是谁的代号呢是大力光的是大力光好 OK所以在下一段節目裡面呢我們就要跟大家分享到底這一次細光子在台積電的加持還有大力光的是大力光所以在下一段節目裡面我們就要跟大家分享到底這一次矽光子在台積電的加持
還有大力光是領頭羊聯亞也創新高的情況下
誰有標股基因等一下一檔一檔幫您數
好 我們來看一下近期的大標兵
大力光
沒錯 很厲害
我們來看一下
其實大力光之前它有法說
它法說說
它有自己
他們自己有說
他們9月的時候一開始很不錯
股價8月就先快一倍
其實他們目前營收都略顯平淡
可是不知道什麼股價已經飆到快8000了
沒錯 其實因為開兩次法說了
它第一次法說是開成法會
因為很老實
說2028才會有CPU
沒錯 然後6月就自己出來講說
9月我們可以好好關注一下
我們的表現
那8月的時候就已經先拉了
接近9成的一個漲幅
那大力光確實
營收可能還沒出來
但是它的動作頻頻
這很猛耶
你就這樣一直買
要是你看到一家保守的公司
一直在買地
對啊
對不對 好有錢喔
你看6月
這個行動力會讓你印象很深
對啊
6月 7月買兩個
然後8月再買兩個
總共買62.5億
所以这个应该是近年
应该非常大的一个
劣地的一个状态了
要是我看到你连买五栋房子
我也知道你发啦
赚大钱了
对啊
就是好明白哦
是的
那目前来说
他们自己有去提到
整个相关的产品
第三季底会建置完成
最快是明年年中会准备就绪
但是呢
也有反而认为
这个平凡的购地
是不是想要大举去做一些状态
或者说他们其实
产业整个的流畅是非常
那个什么
進度是非常順暢的
所以這股價這一波
就搭著CPU的熱潮一起去墊高
當然其實也不只大力光強
但確實CPU其中一個指標股
是看大力光沒有錯
另外一個可能就是看聯亞跟全新
所以目前來說
整個CPU大哥級
或者說這一波先拉起來
只要形態上沒有轉弱的趨勢
可以整理但不要有轉弱
其實我覺得低位階就有機會
做輪動補障了
我們就先把領頭羊神主牌放在那兒
然後來看誰有標股基因
這個創高的有聯亞
一口氣就回到3000多塊
然後聯軍也創新高了光環處置中還是持續創新高它200啦對 那全新今天也漲停板所以我覺得這些都是創新高的那目前有在漲
但還沒創新高的
就會是這一些
好 補漲型的
是的 那當然
其實頂元也是創新高
因為最近有一些新題材
也是可能前一陣子
沒有列在CPU裡面
那近期有跟著一起去做一個強制表現
就像提到頂元
大力光其實都是
今年才有CPU力多的
这些都是两年前就在CPU的
好 所谓的第一代CPU
没错 那第一代呢
这一次的走势就稍微
比较落后新的一代
但我觉得形态都打出来了
所以后面CPU就那几支
只要这个题材一直在
我觉得落后补涨是有机会的
那目前来说整个的营收
还是有一些是EPS是负的
那就是台积电的这个上权
然后光环
光环应该后续会非常不错
因为有一个转机的状态
好 那我们来看一下里面几位
首先第一个就是上权了
我觉得它真的有点伤脑筋
因为你看到林亚在冲
那林亚的营收
真的是开得非常的成长率高
可是它到底
要什么时候才要成长
真的就是
难道真的是继续靠台积列吗
不是总是要开始量产
或是说合作进度
应该要有一定的推进吧
但它确实有一下子好了
但马上又回到温温的状态
那不过没关系
我们就来看一下形态
从形态来看好了
是的 形态呢
那這邊大量
大量這地方
然後這裡也挑戰一次 沒有過
那到了前一陣子
最近終於過了
去做突破
那突破之後呢
股價就開始去做一個延伸去墊高了
所以這邊的底部基本上是確立的
對 這個底部是確立的
至少打好一個底了
沒錯 那打好底之後呢
成交量也可以陸續看到
都呈現了一個開始量增
然後價格有去做上揚的狀態
所以目前來說
我們剛剛提到了嘛
一些什麼聯軍啊
还有这个联雅
其实都已经突破
他的自己的高点了
但上全距离他的高点
其实还有一些空间
所以这边有机会
做一个落后补涨的效应
我会觉得在回落过程中
延续趋势都还在的话
要记得去做一个介入的状态
对啊 毕竟是最早就传出
是台积电首批成任的伙伴
对啊 两年前的时候
上全还在双位数
现在一度到900块
快四位数呢
而且那時候講還有人說有嗎
台營有承認嗎
可是後來是真的有講
是的所以目前來說上全底部有一個轉好的形態我覺得在回落過程大家記得可以去沿著均線去做操作因為人家底部是確立的加油 你已經先搶得頭籌了
沒錯 再來看到就是穩帽
穩帽之前就人家說
買穩帽就穩套
去年 去年
那個時候就是養殖場事件
目前都已經結束了
所以穩帽在今年的時候
其實那一段
其實漲幅它是完全領先全新的
前面有到600多
沒錯
不過穩帽這一次反彈
或者說這一波下跌的狀態
其實都遜於全新
因為全新今天已經
前兩天就創新高了
穩帽股價還走到
整個下跌的一個
五成到六成之間的距離
所以我覺得它還有補漲空間
那一樣都零化銀題材
然後這邊形態
也剛做了一個底部的確立
這裡也是一個很明確的N字形
那量价也都是开始拉出来
所以这个才刚跟季线去做一个突破
甚至拉开一些小乖离而已
我觉得这个位阶来讲
当然啦这个都是已经涨上来的形态
可是我们要比较的是那些创高的
那一些创高只要不要重跌
它可以在高档不创高
高档震荡等均线跟上
那这一些开始形态打出来的
距离前高都还有点空间的
我觉得都值得注意一下
因为大家一定会在想
哇CPU这个题材还是很热
那有哪一些我可以
從地位接再買上來
他們可能還是需要有價差
才願意進場
那這些就可以是一些
大家好好去注意的一些標的
而且他們都是
之前大家很關注的
是的
使用朋友應該都
多多少少對他們有興趣過
沒錯
這邊都受傷過
我必須說
對 那時候有興趣都是受傷
這個受傷很重
對 但是這邊跟他講
不一樣
形態不一樣
對 形態不一樣
量價也出來了
好 再來另外一個
就是華星光
好 华欣光是有獎狀的
因為在7月28號有率先獎他
他也是有業績的公司
是的 對
而且從7月28號到現在
是大概一個月就漲了40%
對 所以他其實這一波的時候
是率先去墊高的
但目前來說他的走勢相對
可能前高比較遠
因為他這一波跌的也是蠻重的
對 然後华欣光上禮拜五
才剛開法說
那講的我覺得應該是非常的不錯
所以目前來說
股价上面临了一个短线
就是进处置的状态
它好像还是很容易进处置
对 这边也进处置
这边也进处置
明明是有获利的公司
是的
可是从8月以来
其实大家可以去注意
有一些像热门题材的
然后它进储置的时候
准备要放出来的时候
通常股价那时候
就会开始做表现
你看这里也是一样
这里是进储置嘛
然后股价一放出来
就直接创一个新高
所以这边又进储置
现在储置都五天而已嘛
除非是当充可能要七天
所以这边大家可以
就开始关注一下
也大概剩没几天要出来
下礼拜就要出来了
所以在这个位置上
在这个行情
只要上升趋势现在
那大家就去看一下
它在出關之前
有沒有一些買盤的推升
或者是股價的推升
其實我覺得可以留意
它通常出關的時候
會有一波表現
那目前來說我剛提到了
這個N字型也是有去墊高的
所以前高的距離
又還有一點空間
那這個我就會是覺得
有動能在 形態也打好了
那位階又比較低
資金如果要溢注
通常會先往這種地方去做關注
那其他可能第三梯隊的
像是光盛 波若薇
目前來說形態都還沒有去過
那個平台的高點
好 都差一些
對 所以那個是第三梯次
這一些第二梯次
拉到一個相對高點的時候
那一些第三梯次開始有
跟著類似這樣子轉強的訊號
其實我覺得他們也可以看
對 所以目前來說
其實整個CPU組群都是看好的
只不過以量價關係
或技術面型態來講
我覺得有先不要追的
然後有的是目前還可以看的
接下來還有第三梯次是
底部再等一個訊號的
那其实我觉得
这个族群还是很棒的
是
而且这个族群
你刚刚有讲到吗
虽然华星光很容易被关
可是关出来之后
都有可能酝酿下一波的涨势
这个是我们对CPU
一个之前越关越大为的印象
那个时候我觉得
我印象中有两支
一个是PCB的京居
京居越关越大为
另外一个就是
那个时候的上权
还有光盛
也是越关越大为
所以目前来说
我可以发现一件事情
就是那个时候最强势的
这一波不一定是最强势
但是如果整个形态
它这个资金一直要在里面
去做轮转的话
其实大家投资人或者主力
他也会自己去想
我要一个创新高的联雅
空间不大
还是说CPU同族群
那可能他还在半山腰的
那种形态
他们资金应该都还是会去做轮动的
对 所以这个题材只要一直还在
那我会觉得就是看高去做低
看高去做低
是 因为像大力光它應該是很少會被關的但最近它的風險被關的风险好像也提高了可是市场很奇妙因为投薪一直对它不离不弃嘛
所以到底这个被关
会反而让这个族群变得更活泼
甚至资金流出来
到更多这种刚刚讲二代三代的CPO
好像还蛮值得留意的
所以它是可能继发哥之后
第二个被关的
算是全职或龙头股吧
对 它股本比较不大
OK 那可以啦
好 所以我們就密切的來觀察一下
好 所以如果需要今天節目
所有的圖卡資料
真的要歡迎訂閱一下
我們的趙華愛倫說的YouTube頻道
因為真的很佛啦
就是我們都會免費放在
首頁進來有一個貼文欄
點進去會有這個雲端連結
讓您下載回去慢慢的研究
尤其是廣告回來
我們有一個大來賓
講一個事情真的很重要
如果今天你很喜歡的公司
像最近的新星
像之前的旺戲
像更早之前的光宝科
可能都因为一些事情
忽然打到跌停板
你要减吗
你要怎么判断不是接刀子
而是真的去救到一个好的价位呢
下一段节目的大来宾
就会告诉你他的心法
为什么总是能够买到
低位接的好股票
欢迎回来赵华
欢迎说
我要问艾伦
如果今天一档股票
出事情啊
就像今天我們創反彈高
創新高的公司就不用數了
可是如果他今天是打到跌停
或者是說好像今天新興好了
你敢減嗎
不敢
真的嗎
很多公司怎麼開玩法說變法會
跌停版你敢減嗎
不會 但有遇過買了之後變法會的
你說賭他會好結果變法會嗎
就是他也講得好
但市場就是
我大家都知道好了嘛
一粒多一出來就直接全部倒給你
那你會怎樣 例如誰
那是鼻子摸摸啊
之前有出几个试的嘛
像这次星星剪掉进去嘛
其实上个月
上上个月
也有一个被冲剪掉的
是齐方嘛
可是一看十年前的事情
那怎么办股价也是回不去了
对啊 所以我在他出试的时候
我通常都不会急着想要进场
是 好啦
有因应
你是出试的时候会落跑的
那我们找出试的时候会去救他
我们先来欢迎他
就是我们的救火王
我们的选股教练
黃金右下角 維泰
趙華好 阿倫好 大家好
真的 維泰有發現一件事嗎就大家就找你來的時候趙華就會講說今天那個法會不是啦 法說變法會的叫維泰處理因為有很多次
中頂工程出包
光寶科被外資降頻
旺系前兩天連續的跌停
我們每一次都會說
這一題分給維泰
救火救火
真的太榮幸了
而且維泰都不會拒絕
他都會幫我們
講出一朵花來
好 為什麼呢
因為維泰有練過
那
永春雙拳是真的有練過嗎
我有練過永春拳
是
我的老師是盧文錦老師
哦
然後盧文錦老師是
葉問的外甥
哦
對
是
所以他的秘訣是什麼
呃
永春的心法很多
像我們這邊
跟大家分享的就是兩個
一個叫做追影不追手
追影不追手
對
那這個可能就跟剛剛
趙娃所提到
當一些好公司
對
碰到壞事情的時候
這時候我們會去看一下
這家公司它的體質
是不是有受到影響
對 那麼這個在我們
在練永春群的時候
我們是說我們會看著
這一個對手
他的這個形體
而不是去看他的手
他要怎麼樣去揮動
這個我懂
我看著你的形體
不是看著你的手
我看你的形體
因為基本上是要
打到對方的人
我們不是要打對方的手
甚至不會去
特別去接對方的手
是 對
這個就是追影不追手的一種
永春心法
然後運用在這個
股票市場上面
好 終於聽懂了
第二句也很懸
高腳但是不過膝
膝不是很低嗎
永春懸的踢法
就是高腳不過膝
怎麼踢 對
踢他下盤
這個
有會跟踢他下盤
沒有錯 打他下盤
打他下盤 對
不是要踢他中路嗎
也是
切中路的概念就是
我們投資要切到那個
盤面上面的主流
要切到中路
所以其實我覺得永春新法裡面
有非常多跟這個
投資哲學有關
那麼高腳不過西這件事情
其實大概有兩種說法
相傳在很久之前
少林寺五媒師太
夏三他去教那個
袁永春教他這個拳法的時候
因為呢 這個袁永春他是女生那女生就像趙華這樣穿著漂亮的长裙那在教他这个腿法的时候他不方便踢得高
所以五眉师太就教他专踢
就是所谓的下盘
下三路的一个腿法
那所以传到后面
我们就有听到
就是永春拳的这个脚法
是不会踢高的
那么在第二种说法呢
就是说在食物上
假设我们脚踢得高
踢到膝蓋以上的話
很可能會發生就是
我們的腳被對方的手抱住的情況
然後我們腳呢
只要被對方的手抱住
對方一拉
我們人就會跌倒
所以其實在實戰上面來講
我們的確針對這個所謂的踢腳
我們的確是踢不過人家的膝蓋
好 所以難怪叫黃金右下腳
就是整個人要先穩對不對
當我們遇到像公司跌停什麼
大家都是慌
可是維泰就可以看到
影是什麼
然後高腳不過西
知道它是不是一個好的買點
突然之間覺得頓悟了
我要出家了
OK
這麼突然了嗎
因為維泰之前
幫我們見檢過的公司非常的多
例如說光寶科
可能最近的都還不算是最新的
我印象最深就是光寶科
100塊還在被外資降頻
那時候也是請維泰來講
怎麼100塊還在降頻
還有近期就是世新KY
也是這個法說會後被打下去
那到底要怎樣做到追影不追手
當然今天和昨天
大家最關注的就是新興
所以今天沒有在打跌停
對你來說是一個什麼樣的位階
好 當時呢
在這個跟大家分享光寶課的時候
那個時候是在籌資
那籌資的過程當中
其實如果說是用憲政來看的話
本來賣壓就比較重
因為那個時候
其實會有很多的
所謂賣勞股 任新股的賣壓產生
那麼股價就掉了下來
那這時候剛好碰到
這個外資在這邊去做賣潮
所以這時候我就覺得
那個時候其實對公司的本質來說
應該是沒有太大的影響
反而他未來為了要去做籌資
他一定會想辦法
再把這個股價穩在
一定的一個目標區之上
OK 所以當時呢
這個光寶哥就在低檔
跟大家做了一個分享
好 這還是比較近期
就今年3月24號
我講的100塊是更值錢
所以你救過他
你雪山上救過好幾次光寶哥
終於有報恩的了
對對對對
所以光寶哥現在看起來
的確就是5M
剛剛跟大家分享的
就是它基本上它的一個本質
在這個包括Power Supply
跟這AI伺服器的一個
電源上面來講
它現在是緊追一哥
緊追台達電
那最近的一個股價也是開始
有比較明顯往上去做走高
好 但是如果走到這樣的階段
不需要你救了
會不會反而會去
繼續看其他的環境右下角
我認為其實在
已經漲上去的個股
如果說沒有出現敗向的話
基本上我們就持股
就也不太需要出現
太明顯的就是出脫的動作
那的確是可以把一些
我們的精神去看待其他的
值得我們去做關注的
右下角股票
好 那另外的話
我們也可以看到就是世新KY
其實今天盤面上IP股
也是顯學
因為有這個
研發哥 研發哥跟輝達
那時候講也是
兩根大黑K價來講的
利多便利空
你有講到說
欲加之罪 何患無辭
對 是
當時是因為大家
在憂鬱他的這個毛利率
會下滑的一個情況
可是呢本來在做
Turnkey的一個業務
他的比重一旦拉高
他勢必營收會增加沒有錯
但是呢他的毛利率會下滑
但是等到下一個案子來的時候
他開始去收前期的權利金的時候
那個時候毛利率就會起來
所以我覺得在整個架構來看呢
基本上他對他整體的一個
毛利率來講
並沒有說出現明顯惡化
所以當時市場上面
反映這樣子的利空消息的時候
我倒認為說其實
搞不好会是一个
蛮不错的一个买点
好 就是这个利空是因为
毛利率不如预期
但之后就好啦
对
想法是这样子
那接下来就是
近期的 窄版了
近期的新星
要是你的话会怎么样决定
要不要买新星
我会等事件落幕再说
是
因为这一次有提出来的状态是
PCB的状态
是跟ABF没有关系
但目前来说
他们好像来调查中的话
我可能就不會在現在去積極進場
那薇泰的想法呢
今天土陽對坐
對 基本上如果說
看它的基本面來講的話
ABF載板四上的星星店
在我們這個載板四雄當中
的確它的一個比重是比較高
OK 大概在超過這個65%
然後再來它的產能
規模
或者是它的整個技術基本上都是領先其他的一個同業OK那只不過呢現在大家比較關心的就是說他的資本支出龐大了未來可能這個費用會增加了
或者是現在有一些司法上
查核的一個問題
但整體來看
我們來看一下他的一個財務面的部分
上半年的EPS來看
他賺11.7元
這基本上也是四雄當中
算是比較好的
那法人估他全年EPS
也是四雄當中比較好的
那唯獨就是在本益比的部分
因為它這個EPS高
那大家都覺得它好
所以股價稍微漲比較多一點點
那麼如果說從整個籌碼面來講的話
它的這個董監跟外資
這加加起來將近有50%
那麼雖然說它沒有像是台售一樣
這個董監有61%
但整體來看我個人認為
它在整個籌碼的集中度來講
也還算是高的
所以基本上在基本面跟營運面
還有在籌碼面的部分來看
我都覺得它還是一家
值得長期投資的公司
不過剛剛艾倫也有提到
他會比較著眼於
司法調查中
就好像有點不明朗
這個你會列入考量嗎
我會列入考量
那由於現在的狀況
其實就是大家會關心說
那會不會有這個
擴大調查的一個情況
那如果擴大調查的情況之下
當然它的整個
所以不確定因素
可能還會持續的維持一段時間
但是只要它不確定
因素維持一段時間
造成股價更下跌的話
我反倒認為它越跌
反而越是它投資價值
浮現的時間點
維太斯講得很肯定的
不像我們都模仁兩可的
想要回避這個問題
沒有開玩笑
因為今天是報了一個
大量9萬多張
承接的意願很重
今天這個地方
報9萬多張
是有它的一個原因的
我們來看一下
因為今天的價格
剛剛好是回測到之前
在6月底的時候
當時這個地方有一個
7萬多張的大量
對耶
所以它其實是一個
同位量的概念
這個價格呢
對過來剛好就是今天
早上開盤的一個位置點
所以在這個位置點
似乎有一個
這個所謂看不見的時候
去進行防守跟支撐
所以我覺得今天
報大量是合理的
但是報完大量之後
也就是明天跟後天
就特別重要
因為這個爆量看起來就是土洋對坐
因為今天的外資持續站在買方但是投信這邊有出現一點轉賣的一個情況那這時候就要去評估這個投信的這個轉賣
是不是因為
基金公司他們的內規
他針對某一些
他們過去認定的一些
例如說
可能有法律訴訟
相關的議題的公司
他們不要碰
或者是呢
就是例如說
像是其他的一些
下跌或是有一些
不確定因素
他們必須要去做一個
減碼碟一個操作
所以也未必是這個投信
他們真心想要去做賣出
那麼像今天下午
我看了一份
就是人家整理的報告
就是包括像主動式基金
各個主動式基金
對於這個新興店
在這次事件
他們的一個評估
基本上都還是支持新興店的
其實外資第一天就都停了
可是因為我們知道
那是外資啊
我們要看自己家投信
沒錯
但自己家投信
也沒有說賣到
大賣特賣這樣的狀況
對 那同時在這個融資的部分
反而趁著這次
這個股價下跌的融資
被洗出去一些
所以我反而覺得接下來
如果說這個股價在這邊
再稍微去做一個震盪一下
然後使得融資再進一步的
去進行所謂的一個
出場動作的話
那搞不好這一波的
一個風波過去之後
股價有可能就是換手
然後再往上去挑戰新高
是 好 哇塞
這個我在講的超級明確
沒錯
追隱不追手對不對
再來就是高腳不過膝
這邊的話
我們之前也有幫雙紅
講過非常多次的話
他現在這個腳應該過膝了
過頭了
長心也是從低檔講到高
所以到底下一個
可以出腳的目標在哪裡
我們來現在看一下雙紅
真的被講起來了
當時講雙紅的時候
我應該是跟大家分享說
这个地方是一个W底
是一个双脚底的概念
而且双脚底完之后
它就回撤
它就回撤这个颈线位置
所以当时我认为说
它的一个底部的一个形态
已经算是很明确的
然后再来呢
大物的十股比例
有在网上做增加
所以包括像是这个技术面
或者是铲码面
基本上都有利于多方发展
好 真的就下来
因为这边真的是双脚底
没有看也知道好厉害
而且重点是
它的七月份营收
是創新高的
所以是委屈的
這從營收來看
長新化工也是講在
這講到最低一點
近期最低一點年限的位置投信買到現在沒有認賠融資反而去下降对 所以这边可以观察到投信真正持续做买超
融资持续的再去做一个
减肥的动作
那当然这个当时前
可能对于这个季限
有点所谓负瓜里
负瓜里比较大情况之下
所以这个地方
比较不见大家去进行这个沙地
好 但是现在都是在头上了
而且投信还在买
投信反而买盘的力道还加大
对 因为投信对于这种
所谓的传产股
他们的主要
通常都不会排在
优先顺序上面
对 所以我觉得这个部分
终究当大家再回头去审视
哪些个股直接做投资
哪些个股它有后市的一个
展望比较好的情况之下
我相信长期应该
都是会被选上的
这个半导体电子级材料
最近有好几档
例如说中华化也很猛
所以刚刚讲的都是
维泰为什么当初
敢在低档讲他们的
那现在还有这些在低档的
一看就觉得没信心
但我一定要加持他们是有信心的
对会让大家没有信心的原因
可能我自己都会有点点就是concent
例如说他前七月份营收
有一些还呈现这个小幅度衰退
跟刚刚那个不一样
这个其实跟大家在
喜欢挑选这个成长股的逻辑是不一样的
因为对我来讲
这个股价值得投资
必须是第一个他股价有落底迹象
然后它的基本面可能最快时间已经过去
基本面是往上的
那当然就像刚刚那个长新一样
它的整个大户的持股是往上做增加
刷红也是
所以基本上在符合这三个条件里面来看的话
有一些个股的确是我最近有在做关注
包括像是东元然后圆柏
中株KY 续准群光跟美食KY等等
他们的400档的持股
大户的持股基本上都很高
都很高
所以在这种所谓的
大户的持股比例
相对比较高
再加上未来
他们各个公司
他们的一个基本面
都有出现
就是好转情况之下
我觉得这些公司
大家可以特别做留意
好 我们等一下就
一个线图一个线图来看
看看观众朋友
你能不能有信心
第一档好歹还是电子股
UPS的续准
其实续准之前
我们在第一档
是有曾经跟大家分享过
那个时候其实
它还没有往上涨
還沒往上漲
它是UPS的一個ODM龍頭
那基本上呢
它在這個不斷電系統
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕